thank you
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
Birds hear the word spoken in the day
and mice hear the word spoken at night
the only impossible journey is the one
you never begin
be strong enough to know that you could
do anything you want and wise enough to
know that you shouldn't do everything
[Music]
the only way to do great work is to love
what you do
at the end of hardship comes happiness
you'll lose the one in your hand trying
to catch the one on the Run
[Music]
your future depends on what you do in
the present
[Music]
life is either a daring Adventure or
nothing
if you don't walk today you must run
tomorrow
Rome wasn't built in a day
[Music]
travel is good but staying at home is
better
foreign
is one who walks in when the rest of the
world walks out
[Music]
we don't know how to be happy because we
don't know we are happy
you can't buy friendship with money
walking with a friend in the dark is
better than walking alone in the light
foreign
[Music]
it does not matter how slowly you go as
long as you do not stop
learn to walk before you run
[Music]
even monkeys fall from trees
don't let yesterday's failures ruin the
beauty of today
because each day has its own promise of
love joy forgiveness and New Beginnings
foreign
to start well is half the race
say pretty things to hear pretty things
[Music]
tomorrow will be better than yesterday
forget what hurts you but never forget
what it taught you
the best medicine for regret is not time
but becoming a better person
a stranger nearby is better than a
relative far away
a great River does not refuse any small
streams
don't throw dirt into the well that
gives you water
there is no winter without snow no
spring without sunshine and no happiness
without companions
[Music]
foreign
if heard too often
a fish wouldn't get into trouble if it
kept its mouth shut
you cannot strike a face that is smiling
[Music]
the Journey of a Thousand Miles begins
with one step
success is not the key to happiness
happiness is the key to success if you
love what you're doing you will be
successful
our greatest glory is not in Never
Falling but in Rising every time we fall
[Music]
your present circumstances don't
determine where you can go they merely
determine where you start
believe you can and you're halfway there
[Music]
everything is hard before it is easy
the future belongs to those who prepare
for it today
from a dirty spring flows dirty water
[Music]
if you really want to you can fly into
space
[Music]
The Darkest Hour is before the dawn
health is not everything but everything
without health is nothing
if kind words come from you then kind
words come to you
don't look at a tree you can't climb
don't wave your fists after a fight
the lack of news is good news
a beautiful flower doesn't always smell
good
foreign
without cracking a nut you will not know
its taste
whether there is a lot of rice in the
cup depends on how much you put in it
don't put both feet into one pant leg
another's cup always seems bigger and
your own cup always seems smaller
the Hedgehog considers the skin of his
children soft
other people's flowers are always
beautiful
it's enough to see a man do one thing to
know what he's like at 10 things
[Music]
a load that a horse can handle a flea
can't handle
Let The Cauldron be black but not the
porridge in it
foreign
if you want to pull out the grass pull
out the roots
[Music]
it is not necessary to drink the whole
seed to find out if the water in it is
salty
if you don't go after what you want
you'll never have it
if you don't ask the answer is always no
if you don't step forward you're always
in the same place
foreign
bones
when the source is clear then the water
in the lower reaches is transparent
the eagle does not catch flies
when there is no rice porridge Bean
porridge will do
[Music]
even a beautiful sight is not
interesting to watch if you watch it
alone
[Music]
strangers can just as easily become best
friends as best friends or strangers
hard work never heard anyone
the three greatest doctors are nature
time and patience
foreign
has no legs but it travels thousands of
miles
it's easier to live without love but
there's no point in living without it
if a person does not know which Port he
is sailing to there is no Tailwind for
him
[Music]
treat the others to ten pieces of meat
and you will be treated to a peace
someday
foreign
to whom the soul lies to whom the feet
carry
stars shine to those who look at them
[Music]
if the loser Smiles then the winner
loses the taste of victory
love is when you can't stop getting
wounded
it's better to get a slap in the face
from the truth than a kiss from a lie
when you lift together it's better even
if it's just a piece of paper
[Music]
the smallest decisions can change your
life forever
[Music]
your dreams are sure to come true when
others see how hard you try to make them
come true
he who has a bad wife is poor in the
midst of riches
there is no cure for love except to love
even more
[Music]
he who does not make mistakes on the way
to achieving his goal is not trying hard
enough
[Music]
work until your Idols become your rivals
foreign